you
one two three four five six seven eight
one one two three three four five 5 six
6 seven 7 8
[Music]
right alright
one two one two
[Applause]
[Music]
okay one two one two
you
we were all looking forward to yet
another conference at the Oslo Spektrum
unfortunately with the current corporate
19 situation it's not safe to do so
even though we can't meet in person for
this year's conference we look forward
to engaging online when life throws a
curveball at you it's how you react that
matters cancelling the conference was
never an option not for us and not for
you thank you so much for attending if
you have any questions we are available
on slide we also have a WebEx meeting
where you can meet us in person at the
info booth channel to all of our
speakers that are presenting to you from
their homes we know you were looking
forward to the shrimp cruise we'll have
to say that for next year thank you so
much for speaking to all our fantastic
partners thanks for sticking with us
through this you rock these are awesome
companies special thanks to our
exhibitors you'll find them at our
virtual Expo make sure you visit them
there are some amazing prizes to be won
we'll do live prize draws during every
lunch break thanks to the gender
committee for putting together a
fantastic agenda you did a great job so
where we are in the world we hope you
enjoyed the show anything you want to
add to this duel
[Music]
good morning NDC I believe we are live
on YouTube how is everybody so first of
all welcome all of you welcome that's
that's kind of an interesting word you
know because welcome and you know it's
its contemporaries Val come Val Val
common and Romance languages Bienvenue
BIM van Berg bienvenida they all mean
the same thing they mean a a sense and
expression of joy that somebody has
arrived and nobody has arrived at home
I'm at home I'm streaming this to you
live right now we should be here this is
where we're all going to be meeting up
this summer for you know NDC Oslo one of
the biggest and best developer
conferences that happens anywhere in the
world but of course that's not happened
but it's okay we have adapted everybody
has adapted all of our speakers have
turned their homes into broadcast in
recording studios and are gonna be
sending this out live to you from from
wherever they are you are joining us
from all over the world we've adapted
parties into live streams we've turned
our workshops into webinars and without
realizing it we've adapted our own
language to suit these strange and
welcoming times and when I say welcome
you don't need to arrive anywhere for me
to mean that it's an expression of joy
that we are together and we are able to
be part of this and we are living
through some astonishing times this is a
quote from a Satya Nadella a few months
ago he said we've seen two years worth
of digital transformation in two months
from remote teamwork and learning to
sales and customer service critical
cloud infrastructure and security we are
working alongside customers every day to
help them adapt and stay open for
business in a world of
remote everything think about that a
world of remote everything because our
world has changed dramatically in the
past few months and you know we've all
changed with it there are companies that
said that remote working was not a
possibility it was never something we
were going to be able to do suddenly
they're like well you can do remote
working or you can close the doors and
go out of business and they figured out
how to do things remotely how to do
remote meetings how to do remote
collaboration and and you know when
people talk about remote working some of
us have been talking about that for
years this is not what they had in mind
you know we are not expected remote
working doesn't mean trying to do your
job and teach your kids at the same time
remote workers can go and meet their
friends after work and you know have a
drink remote workers can go outside they
can jump on a plane go and see family
work from somewhere else for a couple of
days this is not remote working but
somehow all of you all of us have made
it work anyway so first of all this
morning everybody out there give
yourselves a massive round of applause
for being flexible and adaptable and
coping with this astonishing situation
that the world has thrown at us come on
I said a big round of applause now it's
a testament to human ingenuity and
adaptability that you know all of this
stuff has worked but you've got to admit
that the technology has helped that
broadband you had put in your house so
that you could watch Breaking Bad on
Netflix actually turns out that's pretty
good for running video meetings that
shiny shiny laptop you bought well turns
out it's got a pretty good built-in
camera you can use for doing remote
stuff and the crazy colored world of
warcraft gaming headphones well that's
your stage microphone now that's your
conference call system now all of this
technology you know it's an amazing
testament that all of us have managed to
do this in a lot of cases with kit we
already had stuff we just had in the
house which is great because Amazon sold
out of webcams like in March and they're
not getting any more back until August
but I wanna take a moment and contrast
you know now we think that that NDC oslo
last year was normal and the one that
happening now is weird but communication
and technology and conferences are
constantly evolving you know so in a
normal conference in DC last year lots
of digital projectors lots of HDMI lots
of free Wi-Fi but when I start traveling
again after this thing is over I'm gonna
be taking one of these because the
number of places I go that haven't got
HDMI yet and my first job does anyone
know why a PowerPoint slide deck is
called a slide deck and my first job I
used to make PowerPoint slides I would
load PowerPoint 97 and I would make
slides and then I would send them by
ISDN to a bureau and a couple of hours
later a courier would arrive at my
office with these slides physical 35
millimeter slides communication is
always evolving this is just the latest
chapter in how we adapt technology to
run events and conferences and the
things we do but you know communication
is it's existed for as long as humans
have existed and that's what I want to
talk to you about today because
communication is amazing think about it
from the moment we're born
we're learning to communicate we're
learning to understand the world around
us through pictures we draw pictures of
our own we learn to read we learn to
write and in doing that we unlock the
super power that has made human being so
astonishing the ability to assimilate
information that we didn't have to find
out for ourselves in the course of
putting this talk together I learned a
lot of things that I didn't know when I
started I learned things that made me
happy I learnt things that made me sad I
learned things that change the way I
communicate and things that made me help
me see the world in a different way and
now with an hour of live streamed
conversation and PowerPoint I'm gonna
share all of that with you and maybe
make you happy make some of you said
change the way you see the world so
let's start at the beginning
it all starts about 5000 years ago we've
been using stone tools for about three
million years at this point so we got
stuff we got gadgets you know that three
million years human beings have been
wondering
planet Earth hitting stuff with sharp
rocks and setting it on fire and
evolving the whole time and along the
way we've learned to talk we don't know
when we learn to talk because there is
no primary record speech doesn't exist
doesn't leave any traces but at some
point we've developed language and now
5000 years ago we're hanging out in Iraq
back when it was known as Mesopotamia
and somebody is about to have a good
idea they're thinking you know this this
speech and this language is all very
good but what if I could make some marks
on a bit of clay and then next time I
need to know how many goats my friend
Anki has got I don't need to go and ask
him I can just look at the tablet now
yes they almost certainly wrote on other
things we always have this idea about
clay tablets
there was probably vellum and papyrus
and any number of other things but the
invention of writing goes back like I
said about 5,000 years ancient
Mesopotamia and the earliest writing
systems were pictographic if you wanted
to send somebody a letter saying three
cows you would draw cow cow cow and send
it to them send them the clay tablet or
maybe you draw a picture of a cow and
three stripes one two three to denote
three of them and then you know Enki
would get your clay tablet and look at
it and be like three cows whatwhat three
cows has Nisha lost three cows neeshub
looking for three cows does he selling
three cows because in anthropological
terms there is a lot going on right
about now for the first time in history
humans are settling down with growing
crops instead of being nomadic
hunter-gatherers we're starting to
develop concepts like ownership and debt
and tax and when invented money yet but
we've invented writing and we are
already starting to grapple with a
problem that some of you are still
grappling with today
how do you take an abstract idea and a
concept and communicate it visually well
let's play quiz time so I'm going to
show you a bunch of slides and the
answer to every slide is the name of a
country we got to play a couple around
see how you all do surround one start
you off with something nice and easy
what country do you think that is yes
well done
Spain you're clearly on fire this
morning how about this one what country
United States of America correct well
done how about this one here alright
they get a little bit harder you get
Australia well done give yourself a
point we'll be giving out some special
transparent gifts at the end of the talk
how about this one how about this one
now this one of course is ice land and
this one is boat Swan a this is what's
wanna how about this one
can anyone read this this is Canada but
it's Canada written in an alphabet that
many of you are probably unfamiliar with
and this one here yes that's right
this is the flag of South Africa now
that little quiz there I have showed you
a bunch of different ways of
communicating and the first one that
we're going to talk about is something
called photographic communication now
this and this and this and this they say
the same thing in Phonographic
communication the marks on the paper or
on the screen they stand for sounds and
all of these sounds here the top one
here is Japanese the next one down is
Korean Hangul Cyrillic Russian and
English
all of them say na da and to know what
that means we have to be able to one
read the marks on the paper but two we
need to understand what those noises
mean the word Canada has to have meaning
for us if I ask you to read this word
here now most people I suspect if you
can read the English the Western Latin
alphabet you'll look at this and you'll
go vertical via hippo and you'd be
correct that's the sound that this word
makes but unless you speak Finnish
you don't know that Avatar mo is one of
these a hippopotamus finish is a
phonetic language almost all of the
letters in written finish and Czech and
Russian they always sound the same Evert
in Finnish is always now in English
things are a little different
let's talk about well let's talk about
this this this here this is Greg the
giggling Goose and Greg thinks that gif
files are called gif files because get
that shape there means the hard G this
is Georgia the ginger giraffe and
Georgia who loves geology thinks that
jiff files are called jiff files with a
soft G and this is chap here this is Lea
the Gnostic mu and Lea thinks that the
letter G shouldn't be pronounced at all
and that these are called if files now
English pronunciation is complicated in
Finnish this is always yeah it is never
any other sound in Spanish this is
always as in jalapeno in English this
could be a J as in juice or it could be
a year as in Jagermeister or it could be
a ha as in jalapeno now anybody who grew
up speaking a sensible language like
Czech or Russian or Finnish and who
started learning English later in life
there's been moments where you've looked
at something and you've gone neither
this is a joke someone is having fun
here because English spelling has very
low something called phonemic
orthography how consistent how regular
is the spelling of that language I take
it you already know of tuff and bow and
coffin dough of Istanbul but not you on
hiccup for a slough and through well
done and now you wish perhaps to learn
of less familiar traps
beware I've heard a dreadful word that
looks like beard and sounds like bird
and dead is said like bed not be for
goodness sake don't call net deed watch
out for meat and great and threat they
rhyme with sweet and straight and bet
and so on and so on and there are entire
poems dedicated to the irregularity of
English spelling now one of the lovely
things about being a
to travel the world whether physically
or digitally and you know hang out and
talk to all of you is everywhere I go
almost everywhere I go people speak
English which is brilliant for me
because that's the language I speak and
it's the language of the International
technology community and I always try
and make a bit of effort I try and learn
a couple of words and so when I go to
somewhere like Norway this is what
normally happens is I see a word that's
written down and it looks almost
familiar apart from these funny little
extra bits that I don't know how to read
because no one ever taught me and so I
panic for a little bit and I go alright
lope are just like no other bits like
don't understand and I'll ask if anyone
has a half owner and everybody roars
with laughter and I get in a round of
drinks and everyone responds in perfect
English and it's absolutely normally
absolutely fine after that but I want to
introduce you to a friend of mine this
is Magnus Martinson no sorry let me
credit this is Magnus Mortensen and
Magnus is from Sweden Magnus was
speaking at NDC a couple years ago and
and Magnus travels all over the world
like many of us do and he speaks at
these kinds of Technology conferences
and a few years back Magnus was on his
way to the United States of America now
Magnus has a Swedish passport and that
letter that are in Magnus's name the a
with a little circle on it in Swedish
and Norwegian and Danish that is a
different letter of the alphabet
it's a letter that doesn't exist in
ASCII so when somebody has to put Magnus
into their mainframe computer system
that was probably designed by people who
speak English they got to decide what to
do with that little a with a circle
sound now the Swedish authorities who
issue Magnus passport they say that you
should replace that with a a so that it
comes out as a Magnus Mortensen and if
you know the Danish City of Aarhus
that's actually at the end of the
alphabet after Zurich if you're being
strict because AAA is a different letter
but the people who gave Magnus his
airline ticket they didn't follow the
Swedish rules they followed some
different rules they just took the
circle off so he was Magnus Martinson
and of course what do you think happens
if you try and enter the United States
with
passport that doesn't match the name
that is on your boarding ticket there
were a lot of very uncomfortable
questions eventually they let Magnussen
but you know Magnus is a well-dressed
articulate charming white guy traveling
to a business conference how different
do you think that situation could have
come out now one of the fascinating
things about studying languages and
alphabets and stuff is the realization
that the language you grew up with the
one that you assume is you know that
one's right and it's all the others that
are difficult that has just as many
drawbacks and floors and quirks as any
of the others there is this expression
in English the usual you walk into a bar
and the bartender says hey what'll it be
John and you say the usual please and
I've noticed over the last couple years
people here in London have started
shortening that to the yoozh now how do
you spell huge what'll it be John are
the the you snow that's already
something that's the huge the the huge
yeah I just have a pint of lager please
because we're using the wrong alphabet
if John was Russian he could walk into a
bar
shut the bullish pit what do you want to
drink and John could say now this is the
Cyrillic letter u it is always
pronounced U and this is the Cyrillic
letter J that is always pronounced sure
so huge is unambiguous now you cannot
order very usual in Russian because
Russian doesn't have and it doesn't have
a definitive article so maybe what we
really need to do is to combine the
alphabets until we get one that covers
all the different bases v huge please
now it's backtrack a little bit in our
country quiz you remember this and you
remember this these are pictographic
languages this that the Statue of
Liberty in the outline of Australia
these symbols look like something in
reality they have meaning for us because
we recognize them from things you can
actually see whereas this the flag of
South Africa this is what's called idea
graphic language this doesn't
look like anything we've all just
learned what this means it's something
we have been taught we have a visual
association between this symbol and the
concept of the nation of post-apartheid
South Africa because obviously the flag
has changed
now here's another symbol a piece of
visual communication that all of us have
been using a lot over the last couple of
months what does this mean yeah that's
right
this means chat this is one of the most
widespread idea grams in all of human
culture almost every culture in the
world has this symbol to mean people are
talking now you know this isn't real no
human being in history has ever had a
conversation by making a white oval full
of written words appear above their head
but we all know what it means and if
you're in a video call or you're in an
app on your phone and you want to open a
chat you look for the bubble with the
arrow and designers know we're gonna
look for it and so the chat bubble sign
gets more and more stylized and abstract
many of you are probably looking at one
of these chat icons on your screen
somewhere right now but as long as we
can find it that's probably okay and so
I mentioned there are four different
kinds of communication this is
pictographic communication it's a
picture that we recognize from real life
this is photographic communication the
shapes means sounds the sounds get put
together into words the words have
meaning this is idea graphic
communication now the fourth kind many
of us here in in Western Europe and the
United States have never come across
this before but the Fourth Kind is
logographic communication this symbol is
the Chinese word tongue it means chat
it doesn't mean now if I ask someone to
read the little bubbles out loud they'd
say you know maybe chat or chatting or
talk or parlay there's all these
different ways of getting from the
symbol to the meaning and they don't all
go via the same word in logographic
languages the symbol is a word and you
can read the symbol out loud and if you
ask a hundred people to read the same
symbol assuming they can read Chinese
they will give you the same sound same
word every time now software user
interfaces are a spectacular mashup
logographic and pictographic and
ideographic communication is the toolbar
in Microsoft Word 2003 now that new
document button over there the little
white square that's pictographic you are
supposed to think I need a new document
I'll start with a blank sheet of white
paper there it is I will click the
picture of the thing that I want click
and you get a new document and next to
that there is the yellow cardboard file
because all of us obviously keep our
Word documents in a yellow cardboard
file right you will do this and the next
of that there is an icon which has a
backstory all of its own now when
Microsoft Word first introduced the GUI
people had blue floppy disks so this was
pictographic to save your document you'd
get a blue floppy disk of a drawer in
your desk and then you'd look at the
screen and go is there button that looks
like one I think I need to click it and
save file that's what we do there are
people using word today who have never
seen a floppy disk kid comes downstairs
with a floppy disk they found in a
drawer and says mummy why did you 3d
print the Save button and so this symbol
has gone from being pictographic to
being idea graphic without the symbol
changing at all now you know what I
really want to know about Microsoft Word
is who goes around in the night and
takes the files off the blue disks and
puts them back in the yellow cardboard
file so we can open them the next
morning I don't think they really joined
this one up and they've started to
change some of these symbols and some of
these ideas if you look at word you know
people they let go the stuff hard but
finally we have a slightly more coherent
user interface the floppy disk save icon
is still there that still exists still
up in there in the top left corner and
but you know we now have if you want to
paste something there's this clipboard
and the cut is a pair of scissors and
the piece thing bottom right there
that's a brush that's a paste brush now
have any of you out there ever made a
document by cutting something up with
scissors copying it and pasting it onto
another another piece of paper I have
many years ago and then we have a whole
bunch of names and icons and letters and
we have bigger and smaller fonts which
taps into the idea of metaphor which is
a whole talk wall into itself but
because we live on a planet with gravity
big things
up and little things are down and big
things are loud so we turn up the volume
and little things are quiet so we turn
down the volume and we want to make it
our front bigger we scale it up towards
the sky and we want to make text smaller
we Scout towards the ground and then all
the way over here past all these icons
there is a button normal now I was sat
there last night and I was I was working
on on some notes for this talk and I
thought I'm sick of this I'm sick of
coronavirus and locked down and the
pandemic and not being able to go
anywhere I miss my friends I want to go
to Oslo I want normal back and I click
normal and you know what happened it
took me italics off my text normal in
Microsoft Word doesn't mean what normal
means in a lot of other contexts and
context is vital to understanding
written communication what does this
mean well we don't know it's a red
circle
it could mean lots of different things
what if we put it on a white rectangle
and hang it off a flagpole and
everyone's like well now obviously it's
the flag of Japan but what if we take
exactly the same symbol and we put it on
a button and we put a green Arrowhead
next to an ILO we'll obviously it means
record and there's a lot going on lots
when rap here red means danger because
the record button would overwrite the
tape and destroy whatever recording was
underneath these days we don't have
magnetic tape of course but record is
still red because record still means
danger because record means someone is
recording the zoom call for your
birthday and in the morning they're
gonna put the drunkest bits up on social
media um in China red doesn't mean
danger China red means luck joy
happiness and next to our red button
we've got this green playback button
because green means go unless you're one
of the 1 in 12 men or one and 200 women
who's red-green color blind but that's
okay because we have different shapes
for you and because in the West we tend
to read from left to right arrows
pointing to the right mean go forwards
progress that arrow is pointing the
other way mean stop backwards reverse
undo and it's interesting that this
metaphor of playback being to the right
takes place even in languages that read
in the other direction this is
you tube and look at that the play
button there is pointing to the left
this is YouTube in Hebrew and Hebrew
reads from right to left
everything here is flipped everything is
the other way round but the play button
is still pointing from left to right now
context is absolutely vital to
understanding how the software we build
effects our users experience and
perception and these kinds of things I'm
sure more than a few events recently the
corona virus pandemic has disrupted
everybody's plans for this year and lots
of things are getting canceled events
conferences concerts are being canceled
and I'm sure a couple of dozen times a
day some of you look at a dialog box
like this which has a button on it
marked cancel and we click cancel
without a second thought because we
speak of Microsoft Windows where cancel
means take me out of this dialog and
please do not change anything and a few
years ago I was working on a payment
system with a big online payment
provider and I was going through looking
at some authorization transactions in
their dashboard and you know these is
where a customer has gone through and
given us permission to take money from
their credit card later so we can do
recurring billing and stuff and I click
on the wrong record and I get this thing
pop up and it's a dialog box and I click
on cancel and I get a thing saying are
you sure you want to cancel because this
was written by people who are thinking
like bankers and in banking if you're
looking at a credit card authorization
and you put cancel it means cancel the
authorization it doesn't mean cancel the
dialog box now this kind of stuff these
these colliding contexts if it happens
in meetings and stuff it's a pain in the
ass you build a system for modeling a
school and you've got a class for
students and a class for teachers and a
class for classes and then someone says
can you make a new class and you say you
mean a class class or a class class and
we have online shops where we put orders
in a database and then you have to
select star from order order by order
and you know if it happens in meetings a
big deal if it gets that if it escapes
into software it can give your users a
really bad day but if you establish your
context strongly enough you can throw in
expressions which would be completely
nonsensical anywhere else and the
context is so strong they make perfect
sense have any of you ever worked late
at the office and you're part
Seiler you're gonna be home tonight and
you're like now I gotta stay late and
squash some bugs and you know if you
didn't know about software what would
you think that person was doing in the
office by themselves late at night and
my favorite example of this ever is if
you get the context embedded deeply
enough you can throw in things like this
Microsoft Excel a serious business
application used by millions of people
all over the world actually has a
setting in it called PI explosion and
you can turn it up to 100 and have 100%
exploding PI's and nobody thinks this is
funny
this will never be not funny now all of
these different writing systems idea
graphic vidya logo graphic Phonographic
they all give us a way of preserving a
message because writing is really a way
of sending messages through time it's a
way of taking a message from the past
and streaming it to the future we can't
send messages back in time yet we're
still figuring that part out but our
society is built on messages that have
been handed down from history from the
Bible to Beowulf to the Dead Sea Scrolls
to the Declaration of Independence
people have put these messages on paper
or in clay or on line and they've
influenced future generations
well sending messages through time is
all well and good what if we want to
send a message across space what if we
want to talk to somebody who's in
another town on another continent well
turns out we've also been able to do
that for thousands of years as long as
you know what that message means
[Music]
that believe it or not is not actually
documentary footage um but human beings
have used this idea ascending using fire
and light to send signals for countless
centuries it's been used throughout
history and it works because we agree
what the light means if you're out at
sea at night and you see a bright light
it means stay away there are dangerous
rocks here and in the Lord of the Rings
there that signal beans one thing Gondor
calls for aid imagine that imagine
riding to war on one bit of information
one boolean flag I've worked with people
who've been through a two hundred and
fifty megabyte briefing video ten emails
a formal spec 19 user stories and they
still can't work out what to do next
when we can agree in advance what we can
talk about we can use fires mirrors and
bells to send across huge distances but
to really communicate we need a way to
send any message and you know for a long
time the only way to do that was to send
a messenger via 490 BC a messenger
arrived in the city of Athens with
important news the Greeks had defeated
the invading Persian army immediately
upon delivering the message the
exhausted messenger collapsed and died
to deliver that news he had splintered
the whole way from the site of that
battle of a forty kilometres away
his name was Philippa Dee's and the town
he'd run from was called Marathon now
you can get faster in the 1860s the Pony
Express made this amazing claim that
they could get a message across the
United States in ten days now you know
that might not sound like a big deal but
according to Wikipedia when President
William Henry Harrison died in 1841 Los
Angeles didn't find out for over three
months it took a long time to get
messages across America and Pony Express
couriers had a brilliant tech startup
they had stations every 10 miles riders
had to weigh less than 57 kilograms
although for some bizarre reason they
needed light people who were good on
horseback but they still wouldn't
consider employing women and you know
they didn't
even think of it writers would write
from station to station to station a
writer would travel 100 miles in a shift
passing on goods mail and everything at
every single post and switching to fresh
horses they were allowed to carry a
revolver and a bottle of water and that
was it they traveled light apart from a
la mochila the backpack containing the
all-important Pony Express Courier
package but if we really want to send
messages fast we need to look better
than horses we need to send them on
electrons now turns out we've learned
about electricity for almost as long as
we've had recorded history ancient
Egyptian texts talk about people getting
shocked by electric fish and the the
Arabic word for a stingray of stinging
ray is the same word they have for
lightning Barack but one of the most
common warning signs that exists
anywhere in the world is this one
electricity danger don't touch this
you'll get a shock which looks like a
stylized bolt of lightning now do you
recognize this or have you just learned
what it means electrical Telegraph's
around 1838 the first electrical
Telegraph systems came into prominence
deckled Samuel Morse in America invented
a 2 wire telegram system he also
invented this code code that bears his
name anyone tell me what this says stick
it in the chat you win yourself a
special limited edition PNG now around
about the mid 19th century 1851 they had
a conference and they ratified Morse
code as an international convention for
establishing Telegraph messages now
within a couple years there's a
telegraph network in North America
there's a telegraph network in Europe
this is basically a map of the business
opportunity that existed and the obvious
question is can we connect those
networks together now telecoms was
basically like startups you put a lot of
money in up front you build a product
and once you've got it you can sell the
same product the same cable to the same
people over and over again so here's our
business plan we're going to run a
telegraph across the Atlantic Ocean a
couple of things make this tricky one
nobody's invented the Telegraph yet so
if our team in Ireland need to talk to
our team in Canada we got to get on a
boat and I'm speaking of boat sir we're
gonna need to borrow
big ship in order to make this thing
work we gotta need cable quite a lot of
cable now if you know anything about
electrical circuits the first thing
you'll notice about submarine Telegraph
cable is it only has one wire
there's no circuit well that doesn't
matter the ground wire on this the first
submarine Telegraph cable was literally
a wire that ran into the ground so we're
gonna take seven strands of copper wire
make it into a wire about two
millimeters thick
we need to waterproof and insulate it
because it's quite wet at the bottom of
the Atlantic Ocean and electricity and
water don't really go together
now synthetic rubber hasn't been
invented yet but there is the substance
we can use called gutta-percha some
rubber SAP comes out of a tree plant
tree bark and the brilliant thing about
gutta-percha is when it gets cold and
when it gets compressed it becomes a
better insulator bottom of the Atlantic
few degrees above freezing 300
atmospheres of pressure not bad
only problem is that enough cable to
cross the Atlantic weighs two and a half
thousand tons there is no ship in the
world that can carry that much so we're
going to borrow another ship and yeah
this gives you some idea of the
logistics involved in the first
submarine Telegraph cable but eventually
1857 two ships set sail from Valencia in
Ireland the USS Niagara and the HMS
Agamemnon couple of days out to see the
cable snaps after three hundred miles
they try and dredge it they recover it
eventually the weather's closing in they
give up they go back to harbor for the
winter they tweak their approach they
refine their instruments they come back
next year with a different plan this
time they are gonna meet in the middle
of the ocean and sail in opposite
directions pinging each other backwards
and forwards along this cable as they go
first attempt they got a hundred
kilometres out and then the cable failed
nothing went wrong at either end just
something down in the murky depths of
the Atlantic severed the cable everyone
was a little bit disheartened they went
back to the rendezvous started a fresh
piece of cable off they went that one
broke they went back to harbor a few
weeks later they came out they tried
again the weather was on their side the
equipment worked flawlessly and in
August 1858 America and Europe were
connected for the first time and Queen
Victoria sent a historic telegram
to President James Buchanan hey and he
sent backs up this was brilliant for a
while
this was the dawn of a new era in
transatlantic communication but
something happened that will be familiar
to all of you as soon as the product was
finished the engineers were taken off
the project and the business people were
put on this guy this guy's name was wild
man Whitehouse and he was the kind of
chief electrical project manager on the
submarine Telegraph project he was
convinced if he put more voltage through
the cable you could get more messages
through and make more money and he
cranked the voltage up and up and up and
I ran about 2,000 volts the cable failed
burned out completely the share price
crashed this guy got fired the age of
transatlantic telegraphy was over in
less than three weeks now it would be
eight years before anybody tried again
and when they did they came back with a
couple of new things new equipment new
techniques and most important of all a
bigger ship the Great Eastern this is
isambard kingdom brunel giant iron
steamship and today there are well over
a million kilometers of this submarine
Telegraph cable around the world now
we're gonna have a look at one of them
this cable is called Marya from the
Spanish word meaning tide Mario runs
from Bilbao in Spain to Virginia Beach
in the United States
it opened in 2018 it has eight pairs of
fiber-optic cables in it each pair
carries 20 terabits per second of
network traffic you're a live demo of
the Maurya cable hi because anybody
watching this talk in America anyone
west of the Atlantic right now you are
probably watching it through this Marya
cable two of those fiber pairs are owned
by Microsoft two are owned by Facebook
one of them is owned by Amazon and when
this cable came online 160 terabytes of
bandwidth each of those pairs 20 turbit
pairs had more bandwidth than the whole
rest of the Atlantic cable system put
together there's another one gonna be
coming online this is the brucer cable
if you're watching this talk from
anywhere in South America it's coming
across the Atlantic on Marya then
streaming down the coast on brucer
coming in at a Rio de Janeiro
if you're watching it from Australia or
New Zealand it's probably going over
Marya crossing the United States getting
onto the Southern Cross cable network
and the cables we use today are
infinitely more sophisticated than these
early transatlantic cables we're talking
fiber pairs and 10 kilovolt power lines
to run the fiber-optic repeaters and
we're laying more and more of the stuff
everyday later this year Google's new
cable called Dunant
is going to come on line connecting
Virginia Beach with Santa líderes on the
coast of France
add another 250 terabytes it'll double
the amount of transatlantic bandwidth
and you know the technology has advanced
a bit since the 1860s these cables
aren't invincible they get knocked out
by undersea earthquakes torn up by
shipping anchors and on one occasion at
least bitten through by a shark if one
of them gets damaged traffic reroute s--
we find another way around if several
them are damaged whole countries can
knock off the internet for days at a
time
and that's a big deal because the
internet you know this global publishing
platform we've created we figured out
that with enough bandwidth we can do
just about anything we can have remote
collaborations and meetings we can build
software and distributed systems that
span continents we can hold virtual
online conferences and livestream
performances and watch Netflix and
Disney Plus and high definition films
and perhaps more important than all of
this we can show people our world we can
share our experience and show them what
it's likely to be us because we all have
cameras in our pockets we all have 4G
data now and we have this global
publishing network that supports
high-definition video now when I was a
kid in the 1980s it seemed to me like
everyone was talking about aliens and
UFOs and Bigfoot and the Loch Ness
monster and you know people wrote entire
books and they commissioned TV shows
based on a handful of blurry photographs
you know and maybe a few seconds of
8-millimeter film and I used to dream
Wow imagine if there were cameras
everywhere imagine if we could get
high-definition footage of a Bigfoot and
the Loch Ness monster and my childhood
dream came true you know there are
cameras everywhere but it turns out when
you put cameras everywhere and you give
people a way of publishing the things
they see
you don't get Bigfoot and the Loch Ness
monster you get this you get police
brutality
you get injustice you get racism sexism
misogyny we get video of things that the
government and the media probably didn't
intend for us to see back in 2016
Will Smith did an interview on Stephen
Colbert's show and he said something in
that interview that I've thought about a
lot over the last few weeks
[Applause]
Risa's um's not getting worse it's
getting filmed now I'm not remotely
qualified to comment on whether racism
is getting better or worse
I'm an educated white man I'm speaking
from a position of enormous privilege
here but the amazing thing about
communication I don't need to experience
that to know that it's real you know I
don't have to live it to understand that
it is a real thing and it is important
and that it matters and yes I can watch
it and it is getting filmed and I've
watched as I've watched the news unfold
around the world I've thought about that
quote over and over and over again and
you know as a society and as an industry
we have problems we have problems around
inclusion we have problems around
diversity and race and gender and
culture and there's probably people out
there right now already writing that
tweet about how we shouldn't mix
technology and politics and you know I
went to a conference to learn about
programming and they talked about racism
and stuff well you can't separate
technology and politics you know there's
a global pandemic lockdown right now you
want to take technology out of it you're
at home by yourself shouting it up in
you know the history of Technology is a
history of yes innovation and invention
and ingenuity and it's also the history
of conquest and warfare and bloodshed
and violence you know we've seen today
how language and alphabet and culture
even including systems can affect the
outcome of people's lives
you know what I said it was eight years
between the first submarine Telegraph
cable that failed after three weeks and
the next attempt you know why there are
no telegram sent between Queen Victoria
and Abraham Lincoln when that first
cable was laid in 1858 Abraham Lincoln
was a lawyer within that eight-year gap
he became the first Republican President
of the United States the American Civil
War started and finished the
Emancipation Proclamation the Thirteenth
Amendment of the Constitution of the
United States when President Lincoln was
assassinated in April 1865 nobody in
Europe even found out it happened until
the news bulletin arrived by steamship
twelve days later that entire period one
of the most significant periods in the
history of the United States there were
no Telegraph's and they didn't build one
because people were too busy doing other
things and as for those submarine
Telegraph cables that were made in
Britain that of copper wire and
gutta-percha Britain didn't have copper
mines and rubber trees in the nineteenth
century now bricky
had an empire this is a map of the
submarine Telegraph Network in 1901 and
here are the bits that were controlled
by Britain the British Empire controlled
about 20 percent of the habitable land
area of planet Earth and a huge part of
the technology in the infrastructure
that laid the foundations of the modern
internet was built to help the British
run their empire more effectively you
add in the Belgian Empire the Danish
Empire the Dutch Empire France Portugal
Spain we're talking about a period of
history where hundreds of millions of
people were the unwilling subjects of
European imperialist powers there are
people out there who are still paying
the price for that today and more
importantly there are people who are
still benefiting from it you know now
this talk took a lot of research like
I've been editing Wikipedia articles
because I found better evidence type
research and I was digging through all
of these old sources and documents and
things about the history of submarine
telegraphy and telegraph systems and I
just kept seeing the same faces again
because with the exception of Queen
Victoria pretty much everybody involved
in submarine telegraphy was a white guy
it's been a hundred and sixty years and
Tec is still run by white men with big
beards doing dumb things with
electricity to try and get rich now I
have no doubt that back in the 19th
century there were women and people of
color who could have made astonishing
contributions at the dawn of the
Information Age they were because
history denied them the opportunity to
play their part or maybe they did play
that part and a white guy came along and
took the credit for it you know either
way we don't know who they were but we
also don't know what we could have
accomplished if they had been given a
seat at the table there now there is
nothing wrong with the video stream this
slide is black on purpose this is where
I was gonna put in the you know stock
photography of all the diverse happy
people all smiling together but I want
to do that instead I want all of you to
close your eyes now the last few months
on lockdown we've all been surviving on
deliveries from Amazon and justy and
delivery I want you to close your eyes
and I want you to picture the people who
have come to your door with those
deliveries did they look like you did
they look like me did they look like
your team did they look like the other
folks are here at NDC there's 8 billion
people on the planet
half of them are not male 90% of them
are not white so why is textures so
overwhelmingly full of white guys you
know geography is not a factor this talk
is streaming live to every continent
except Antarctica the last few months
have proof that it really doesn't matter
where you are if you want to take place
join technology and and you know cost
isn't a factor we live in an age where
you can learn everything you need to
know with a hundred dollar laptop and a
free Wi-Fi connection now we're not
going to fix this in one talk we do need
to fix it it matters it is too important
for this to be left to people who look
like me but there is one thing that I
want all of you to take away from this
today I've been you know messing around
with computers since I was a kid I built
my first PC back in 1997 I've built high
availability database clusters I've
configured Network firewalls
and I've spent my whole career talking
about masters and slaves and black lists
and white lists many of us have well
that's wrong I'm wrong I'm sorry you
know um I'm gonna do better it turns out
those things are just words the
technology still works if we call it
something different that's not to say
that it's easy language is such a
fundamental part of our sense of
identity changing the way we talk is
like changing the way we walk or the way
we eat but this is Dec we love new shiny
things let's stop using these words
let's grok some new terminology primary
and secondary database clusters
brilliant they still work
next time you're configuring a firewall
talk about the allowed lists and the
blocked list or the good list and the
bad list you know we don't need to
resort to this language which makes
other people feel unwelcome at the table
when we're making these important tech
decisions and these decisions are
important more important now than ever
we need more perspective we need more
ideas because our industry is doing some
dangerous things we have monetized
attention we live in an age where the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website looking at your articles viewing
your content the more revenue you get
from your advertisers now when you
finish watching this talk YouTube is
gonna recommend something for you to do
next and I guarantee it is not gonna
recommend that you shut the computer
down and go outside it's not gonna tell
you to read a book it is not gonna tell
you to take a break it is going to tell
you to watch another video and after
that it's gonna tell you to watch
another video the perfect YouTube user
is somebody who sits down one day opens
a video and they never leave the house
ever again because we are using machine
learning algorithms to recommend content
and we are training those algorithms
that retention is good if the user
closes the window and goes for a walk
bad algorithm no biscuit you know you
have to realize the the metric these
algorithms are optimizing for is
somebody who consumes content constantly
24/7 and the best way to punch through
the noise and hook somebody's attention
is to tap right into what's called the
lizard brain the bit of our brains that
tap controls fear the bit of our brains
that's wired straight into our central
nervous system the bit of the brain that
is already panicking by the time you
notice that the thing on the counter is
not a spider it's just the tomato stem
and this is what we are optimizing for
we are building machine learning
algorithms running on an
intercontinental computer network that
are scaring the hell out of all of us to
try and make money you know I think it's
well past time that we tried something
new when we started working out how to
convert n DC into an online event one of
the things that we agreed right from the
beginning was people needed to be able
to talk to each other this event is not
about consuming content no matter how
valuable or informative the content
might be we needed to do more than just
take a bunch of videos and put them
behind a paywall you know NBC has always
been about conversations it's about
something we call the hallway tract it's
a bat what happens when people talk to
each other friendship trust insight
collaboration we can tell our stories we
can share ideas we can learn to see the
world from someone else's perspective
now over the next few days you're gonna
see some brilliant talks by some of the
smartest people I've ever met but you're
gonna see more than that because we are
all streaming from home you are gonna
see into our lives you are gonna see our
offices you're gonna see where we work
you're gonna see the art on our walls
and the books on our shelves you're
gonna see the people and the animals who
we share our lives with there's no way
I'm gonna make it through NBC without
one of my talks being hijacked by a cat
and we've figured out how to replicate
just about anything you know we've
figured out how to replicate sessions
how to replicate workshops how to
replicate those conversations let's use
this opportunity to see into each
other's lives to discuss the things that
make us different and celebrate the
things that make us the same and the
things that bring us together the things
we could do together
now speaking of celebration some of you
were NDC Oslo last year and I had the
enormous privilege of standing up on the
stage on Thursday night with a bunch of
good friends
and amazing speakers who turns out are
also really talented musicians and this
year we've managed to replicate pretty
much everything about NBC in the online
format but there's one thing we could
not replicate and that's a live band
turns out there's a really good reason
for that
it's a little something called the speed
of light as you remember light moves
pretty fast 300 million meters per
second in a vacuum now you probably
didn't know this but in fiber optic
cable you're lucky to get 2/3 of that
200 million meters per second that still
sounds like quite a lot but this is me
here in London and and this is my friend
Heather out there in Kansas City
Missouri
it's about 7,000 kilometres between us
now at the speed of light it takes 28
milliseconds for light to get from my
place - Heather's place and bizarrely
there is actually fibre running from my
house almost all the way to Heather's
house BT Infinity connects to the UK
backbone connects to the Maurya cable
connects to the Virginia Beach seaboard
connects to Google Fiber which is
through out KC so we got fibers at 28
milliseconds now it's not a best-case
scenario
it's probably more like 4045 there's an
overhead at each end for encoding
talking about 50 milliseconds of latency
so that's a hundred milliseconds to get
a message both ways now you want to hear
what music sounds like when there's a
hundred milliseconds of latency between
the musicians you know this song let's
get lucky this is the the smash hit with
that absolute killer groove
now let's bring in the latency there you
go
[Music]
the speed of light is pretty fast but we
humans are also incredibly good at
detecting when the groove doesn't work
in life music and 100 milliseconds is
just too much to work with now the speed
of light is just kinda you know it's a
annoyance it's a pain in the ass for
doing life streamed music and these
kinds of things but like many of you a
couple weeks ago I tuned in life online
using these amazing cables we talked
about and I watched the launch of the
SpaceX crew dragon the first crewed not
manned crewed space launch from American
soil since the end of the Space Shuttle
in 2011 now
that launch was only going as far as the
International Space Station 400
kilometres up but as we send satellites
and robots and people out into the solar
system that speed of light thing is
gonna bite us in a big way the moon is
1.25 light seconds away having a
conversation with somebody on the moon
is like playing quake one really bad
dial-up but our next there is neighbor
the red planet Mars
now Mars moves at its closest approach
it's three light minutes away if you try
to play get lucky with a drummer on Mars
you'd be finished before they started
that's how bad the lag is and when Mars
is on the other side of the Sun it's 22
light minutes away from Earth Jupiter 43
minutes away
Saturn is an hour and a half Neptune is
over four hours the challenges involved
in communicating across those kinds of
distances might seem overwhelming but
the amazing thing is we've already done
it and then some Voyager 1 was launched
in 1977 a year before I was born it left
our solar system in 2012 and it's still
out there still transmitting its
instruments still function and it's
still streaming beta back to earth it's
transmitter is about as powerful as a
torch bulb the signals from Voyager take
19 hours to reach Earth but we can hear
it phoning home from 20 billion
kilometres away and eventually probably
around 2025 the decaying plutonium in
its thermoelectric generators will run
out and Voyager will fall silent but
what if we go further what if one day
human beings go beyond Voyager to the
Stars in 2016 we discovered this
earth-sized exoplanet
in the habitable zone around Proxima
Centauri for half light-years from Earth
could we get there I don't know you know
three months of lockdown has been bad
enough I'm not sure I want a 10-15
hundred year space mission where earth
is a fading memory and the Sun is just a
speck in the rearview mirror it takes
four years to send an email and another
four to get a reply saying sorry the
person you're trying to reach is
currently out of the office but think
about this 200 years ago we waved our
loved ones goodbye they got on ships and
headed out for a new life and we knew we
might never see them again never hear
from them again and two hundred years
from now we could be waving our
loved-ones goes by as they board ships
and head out to the stars in search of a
new life knowing full well we might
never see or hear from them again but
right here right now the human race is
more connected than it's ever been we
can talk to each other we can hold
virtual conferences we can make art and
we can make music we can share each
other's stories learn from each other's
experiences and from each other's
understanding we can celebrate the
things that we share we can try better
to understand the things that don't work
and we can keep talking and cue the
music there we go
live just like the animals then
something happened which unleashed the
power of our imagination avert the talk
we learn to listen speech has allowed
the communication of ideas enabling
human beings to work together to build
the impossible
mankind's greatest achievements have
come about by talking
[Music]
and its greatest failure by not talking
that doesn't have to be like this
our greatest hopes become reality in the
future
with the technology at our disposal the
possibilities are invited all we need to
do is make sure we keep talking
thank you was low ceiling slack